yes and then when she takes the mic the
lead mic I was bawling I feel like this
spoiler talk will be determined about
through the points of when we cry I
doing their reject nation we're gonna
talk about them stars born today
damn damn good movie before we go into
this and I'm Lady Gaga I want to say
thank you to everyone who's been
following us the Stardust app people we
are at 7,000 followers on that bad boy
over there with you 30-second reactions
for films TV shows and trailers often do
these like micro sketches here is my
reaction to a star is born so uh watch
this movie last night and well it's
gotta be my favorite movie of the year
so far
Bradley Cooper damn good actors there's
an Oscar nod so duh well Lady Gaga it's
always a great I cried like three times
for three different reasons [ __ ] love
this movie look at the description box
follow us now
okay so star is born this is gonna be a
spoiler talk where hopefully we don't
talk for too long about this when
Bradley Cooper first becomes venom is
Lady Gaga's carnage it all ties in
everyone it was gonna be a senior
whatever weird way to approach her
universe that stars born has to be my
favorite movie of the year so far and I
waited about a day before I said that
publicly because I was like this is just
a raw feeling I'm feeling about this
movie right now so hot up in it or is
this like genuine and I like it this is
not even my favorite genre a movie it
really has stuck with me and I find
myself constantly thinking about it and
then John's and I pretty much on board
I'm sure this is one of your favorite
movies of the year I don't know if you
declared as your favorite so far I'm
still figuring out where that falls I
mean partly to is like parts of it
still just matriculating through my
system it's such a life EMU V that I
feel like it's gonna be kind of floating
around in my mind for a few days you
know one thing I do want to point out is
I noticed that so many critics are
talking about lady gaga
and Bradley Cooper's direction which are
incredible undeniable but the thing I
don't really hear people talk about is
Bradley Cooper's performance he is
amazing in this movie he transformed I
was watching this movie and I would
occasionally get pulled out with the
thought of how did he do this how did he
do such a like a body language subtle
performance with an accent nail did the
whole three-dimensional lifee
performance that he gives while
directing this epic biopic that's that's
one thing I really respect about his
direction to was he treats these
characters like the real people he tells
a biopic because this is not a true
story yeah but it is the true story of
so many hopes and so many people have
lived versions of this very you know
which is what makes it a timeless story
that's been remade so many times yeah to
start off I cried at least three times I
might have cried more it was some
intermittent like single or double tear
yes every time i cry was an entirely
different meeting you know oftentimes
you get tears of a movie they're all the
same reasoning i was moved by three
different ways throughout this film
because I really thought I was walking
into a film where the whole time it
would feel like Bradley Cooper's
DirectTV Humanity project yeah Bradley
Cooper's gonna try to move you to tears
yeah direct she's not even been in that
much stuff I really could have sworn I
was walking into that kind of film and
when it starts it starts off like a
concert movie i watch this at the Dolby
cinema prymatt at AMC I don't know how
worldwide that feeder is watching it
there that they have the the picture
quality of IMAX and the sound quality of
IMAX here the music and to find out that
Bradley Cooper himself wrote or co-wrote
black eyes was a song that I wrote while
we were filming along with Lady gaga on
a lot of these too this is impressive
his [ __ ] because he learned to play and
sing for this movie and then the course
of that he ended up writing songs that
you hear in this film and I'm sure there
are more that are not even in this film
because the songs here are very moving
and important to the film they're more
than just let's take a break in here a
song yeah they serve the characters to
such a degree that the first moment of
major [ __ ] tears steps out on that
stage for the first time and actually
starts to sing in front of people like
especially if you're a creative type of
any kind I think your soul is just gonna
crush like a tin can
yeah you know because it's super
cathartic and super genuine in the way
that they play it and the way they earn
those moments they feel so lived in that
yeah you can't help but get swept up in
them that's a great way to put it as
earning those moments because I like one
thing I found rather smart about this
movie from beginning to end every time I
thought it was gonna go down a cliche
route like this film has elements and
plot points where they introduce
something that you think is okay here's
where this generic things gonna happen
but then they subvert your expectations
and they execute it in a way that you
haven't seen done before okay yeah we
know they're gonna fall in love we know
they're gonna start performing music
together and we know some dramatic
shit's gonna go we all know this is
what's gonna happen but the way it all
plays out is so different than I could
have anticipated right from the very
beginning of their relationship forming
together when they're getting to know
each other there's a line in there that
is thrown in such a subtle way I don't
think really people realize how
important of a line it is that really
determines the the the future of their
chemistry in the relationship of how it
all plays out it's it's when they're
after the grocery store and they're
sitting outside and then she starts you
know singing the game to him it's such a
like a vulnerable it's like kind of
goofy but so
honorable that just work yeah like this
would be a little bit awkward you know
he's doing some like rather intimate
things but he's not kissing her on the
lips or he's not trying to like you know
have sex with her I mean they're like
sucks on her finger at one point
oh yeah it makes you wonder and
especially towards the beginning of like
is this guy sweet or is he kind of
creepy or what's going on like it really
does a good job of showing you him from
her perspective at one point and that's
in that moment when that's how the
grocery store if she says to him you're
gentleman I think because I feel like if
they had had sex or even kissed prior to
that moment where she gets on stage with
him I would have felt very different
about it because when she gets on stage
it's so multi-layered more than you
might realize
because of the fact that they haven't
kissed yet because of the fact that they
haven't slept together yet it's still
about the creativity and so it's so
about the expression there's so much
little details throughout there you were
telling me before we start filming she
doesn't just agree to go to the concert
you know she's like I gotta go to my
work and then she has it's terrible
their work that was set up nicely when
she goes to the concert when he invites
her on stage he discovered that he
finished the song yeah and it shows that
it's more than just he's attracted to
her he wants the investi really but he
truly believes in her and I think in
that moment she's realizing that too
like holy crap this guy is more than
just wants to have sex with me not just
blowing smoke like this dude serious
about these you know beautiful things
that he's told me yeah he's backing it
up about her talent and the belief he
has it her and isn't as many artists
will feel a big thing that limits
artists as their own belief in
themselves in their willingness to step
outside of their comfort zone embrace
the element of fear to get to the other
side of fear and unleash your greatness
and her performance there I love how she
didn't just go out on stage he starts
playing the song and plays like half of
it there's other than the dialogue of
the lyrics the emotion the the visual
storytelling on her face the performance
there of just I have to do this oh god
it's that split second where you watch a
decision happen and it's so tangible you
know when she steps out on stage
I started singing on the secondary mic
I'm just like oh my god you brought up a
Wonder Woman word yeah I felt a similar
vibe when she steps out onto no-man's
land and then when she takes the mic the
lead mic I was boy I feel like this
spoiler talk will be determined about
through the points of when we cry you
know good good touchstones good marks
for the major emotional points of the
movie the movies so life II there's just
such little details I appreciate like
yeah their chemistry is dynamite in this
movie I kept wondering how much of this
was loosely improvised you know like
those are obviously a good script here
is just wondering there must have been
some improv that that occurred this had
to have been built out of just real life
from the both of them because I mean
even though Bradley Cooper is not by
trade a musician or that's not why we
recognize him most of the time I still
got to think that this story runs
parallel to his journey as an actor -
yeah the next scene they're making out
they're ready to just go at it hard yeah
there's like real life ii stuff you just
don't see in movies she starts like
washing her armpit she washes her crotch
yeah just freshness like yeah yeah yeah
and then he's like smoking and then she
comes back and he's knocked out that
moment where Sam Ellie it's like tucking
him and like I love all the unsaid
things between Sam Elliot and Bradley
Cooper throughout this movie yeah like
he really does look after him and her
having to realize in that moment
he's problematic yeah he's a drunk you
know yeah and the movie like brings that
just as an element upfront yeah another
real life II thing is like they wake up
in the middle of the night after laying
next to each other and they and they
make love because the scene we were
gonna get prior there was gonna and that
moment they make love with each other
and it's beautiful and it made me wonder
how does Bradley Cooper correct himself
in a sec as a relationships progressing
every time I thought it would get cliche
it doesn't well never feels like it's
doing anything cuz the script says so it
just feels like you're getting snippets
of a life yes there's something
confusing because the the the British
talent music agent
dude Interscope Records guys I'm looking
at right now in IMDB his name is Raffy
Gavron and his character name is res
Gavroche I don't know what his name may
be his real-life brother is a museum
bassist character entirely off of you
cuz when he showed up I thought okay
here's where this movie's gonna lose me
after all the great concert moments and
then bonding even in the concert moments
or some great touches I love when they
go backstage and they like smokes really
quick takes a drink I'm like you see
that in these movies just like the
in-between stuff of what's going on it
you're so invested in the life of these
people like I said it has this real
authentic biopic vibe one it brings that
up even in just the style like it
becomes clear from the get-go that
everything is gonna be super intimate
and that's one of the things they talked
about earliest on in the movie is like
once you become famous everyone starts
using your full name and I feel like the
one of the most major themes of the
whole movie is they're all just real
people like Bradley Cooper and Lady gaga
are just real regular people and and
that's nothing going back a little bit
for a hobbit to all this like devarone
stuff that's another thing I really
appreciate about Gaga's performance
she's not exactly oh my god you're this
dude how have you not been plucked out
of the crane game of life for perfection
you know simultaneously there's a hint
of she's aware he is that dude yeah like
when they're first seen when they're
backstage and at the gay bar the way
she's interacting with him you could
tell like she's definitely throwing off
the super famous singer guy
it's interacting that what does he
really want is he just want to sleep
with like what is what is this that he
really wants you could tell that she's
also nervous because he's taken aback by
her and impressed by her yeah he also
doesn't know what to believe about her
you know so it's not like it's a
one-note thing of her character is
impressive to him because she's not
fazed by his fame yeah it's so
multi-layered so Lady Gaga's performance
is definitely does all the credit she's
getting is highly deserved but then
going back to the moment where I really
thought the movie was gonna completely
lose me I just kept waiting for this
movie to like oh it's gonna screw up as
a typical when rez approaches her and is
like hey i got a music thing offer you
you know it's a Fame what do you want to
go I could take you there I can pretty
much talk about every scene in this
movie of how I appreciate the little
details because like the following scene
when when she's talking with him about
how he's impressed with her and Bradley
Cooper's is not having it oh yeah he's
clearly like yeah that's cool yes a
million times I think he like falls over
and then just a little moment of Lady
Gaga going don't worry that he does it
all the time people who date drums end
up dealing with it in the public
atmospheres like if I act like it's not
a big deal it's fine but really like
this is a problem in the relationship
it starts acknowledging the jealousy
right away that he's feeling but I
really appreciate that the movie doesn't
take this turn into he's ins he's
insanely jealous cuz it doesn't become
about it doesn't hit it on the nose and
it does that with a lot of things it'll
it'll let you sit there and wonder how
much certain things are affecting the
characters and especially something like
that you watch that little spark of
resentment grow from a non personal
place yeah it's like he still loves her
and is still very much like invested in
her rise but you can tell there's a pang
on that but I thought it was gonna
become he's jealous of the success yeah
she doesn't give a [ __ ] about their
relationship anymore and how she got
this far yeah I really thought we were
going down that path and then sure
enough I realized later on like oh we're
not going they're not doing the movies
kept to its core of their relationship
that this is this is their story they
have their individual journeys but they
have their journey about their
investment in each other she starts
turning into Lady gaga trajectory of her
career starts to very much be
reminiscent of really yeah she was on
SNL at one point in this movie with Alec
Baldwin which hit high-profile episode
great great great cameo you know really
utilize that caviar Lady Gaga's
theatrical performances are very
different than the generic cliche pop
performance she gives in this movie in
terms of the dancing the way she looks
like yeah just like the abduction from
you know the label influence and yeah
cuz they more for it too generic pop
star in real life she's a pop star but
she's got a very unique way of handling
it
she started a whole wave of people doing
those strange I've unguarded yes in her
wink the music though was like this
sounds like a lady Gaga song yeah which
kind of made me wonder what the movie
was trying to say like like it's not
questionable about the character yeah I
mean questionable about is Lady Gaga
feel this way about her own measly
Cooper you know really into that kind of
music or that kind of you know deeper of
pop or whatever if we were to take out
who Lady Gaga is in real life this would
it be a question basically yeah because
it all makes sense it's it's not it's
not this character's music it's not
resemblance at all of the true the
authentic side of this character yeah
it's very much formulated and made to
produce Grammy award-winning songs just
sell record breaking charts but it's not
about the heart and the honesty of her
music so that makes sense but I also
like that she doesn't become jealous she
doesn't entirely lose herself and in
terms of she's diva now you know does it
become like insanely egotistical she
does lose herself in terms of the art
but she doesn't lose herself in terms of
she's not like not loving Bradley Cooper
when even all that stuff has nuance to
because you don't get the sense that she
absolutely hates the pop music path
movies on it's just a bit problematic
and it's straining their relationship
yeah because a lot of this could have
been one no it never does there's this
moment that I thought it was very
impressive and how they handle
because it's like obviously they're
gonna have some fight and then they have
a very vulnerable fight where she's lain
she's laying in a bathtub bathing yeah
so she's naked possible and he's drunk
again he's trying to like just tell her
the truth and he becomes very verbally
abusive and starts calling her ugly that
fight just felt so real like this is how
real couples like this would probably
blowout at each other now must feel
awkward for be intruding on a moment
yeah you know as an audience member
you're like step out this is so
authentic because she's antagonizing him
and he's trying to not go there yeah but
eventually he gets pushed to power and
he snaps I like how it was all it was
nothing about him being jealous it was
all about he was disappointed in who she
was becoming in terms of her art and
yeah I just really respected that we did
not go down jealousy because most movies
would have done that especially when it
starts going as fast where she's
becoming super successful and he's kind
of fading into the background yeah and
like he's becoming secondary guitar
player artists as he's losing himself to
drugs and alcohol yeah they have that
really embarrassing moment where he like
pisses himself onstage in the middle of
her award the other thing about this
movie is there is some stuff that is
very kind of almost horrifying and then
that moment is definitely one of them
when he's getting worse as his addiction
and his alcoholism spirals out of
control those scenes where he's stepping
up on stage or trying to do things in
public or the audio fades out and just
ringing like those movies but especially
in this movie as like watching is like
you can't afford to [ __ ] this up because
it's gonna have such ramifications and
yeah that moment where he totally
humiliates himself and her in her big
moment is just so crushed yeah yeah to
behold
like it's it's almost horror movie-esque
in how uncomfortable and if it doesn't
turn into jeroni my career screw you
know it's still new on it's so it's so
alike of course she's man but she's also
worried of course he's embarrassed but
she's also warlike
both of their performances are insanely
later yeah it's gnarly to me how good of
a job this movie does it because even
when he starts peachy she uses her dress
to try to cover him up yeah she's still
think you know everybody's embarrassing
[ __ ] ever even when she's in the
bathroom and the dads like chill like
even though the relationships the only
time when I thought this movie got a
little ridiculous in terms of cliche was
very very early in the beginning like so
early that I forgot about it right now
this moment the dad is like you know my
daughter's a good singer but here's a
bunch of [ __ ] and why she's not gonna
make it doesn't believe in you know
where this at all of what he's doing you
know I spent so much of the movie trying
to figure out who that actor was and
holy [ __ ] Andrew Dice Clay like I am and
he's a great choice he's subtle enough
that you don't realize the same face
there's some good scenes of them to
Lavezzi when they were like look how
many views it got so many people watch
see ya talking about how to figure out
what are you too busy you know like
that's a good scene and she like gets in
the shower with him and like she's like
this is he's my responsibility
and then maybe when he goes to rehab we
didn't do this whole like let's watch
him go through withdrawals for three
weeks you know let's do that generic
path and then even when she visits him
at rehab and she says to him there's
like this great line of something I just
never [ __ ] hear and movies you know
real [ __ ] when you're sober are you
still gonna love me cuz you were really
drunk you know like that the time we
were together you're a different girl
and kid talk concern things change okay
there's a fort actually there's four
times I cried out when he's apologizing
to her it's such a real apology you know
he's not like breaking down the
exposition of why he sorry yeah it earns
the moment where she says no this is not
your fault that's a disease that moments
earned it's not his fault it's something
that his dad enabled him when he was a
kid and like making him a drinking buddy
this is a disease that wasn't his fault
like it's his responsibility to handle
it now where it's led him to like that
line of saying it's a disease is not
registered to me as
you've been dealing in an abusive
situation now you're justifying it it
doesn't feel that way I'm like it makes
sense why you're able to see it this way
you know like he gets out of really like
the foreshadowing of the suicide moment
what he's talking about like I didn't
read into it the way he even tells that
story and about how he failed that to
make that was his dad yeah I fail to
kill himself then it becomes a laughing
moment fan does not register to me as a
foreshadowing moment oh he's making
breakthroughs in like overcoming this
and bonding with his sponsor you know it
goes that's what I was thinking when I
when that scene takes place Oh totally
all those dynamics of her wanting to
perform and get him back out there it
looks like the relationship was going
great again and he has that song for her
and then when it gets to the end of the
movie when Gavron basically saying that
you're gonna relapse again you're gonna
destroy your career and just her being
married to you isn't embarrassing you
are an ally ability you're building her
a career automatically just by being
married or her it makes sense that he
wouldn't put this on Lady Gaga yeah he
wouldn't that's just his character's
been so well established the course of
this journey yeah he's not gonna say it
Matt's [ __ ] heartbreak look at it
back one more toys like I just want to
look at you one more time and he says
that brings that line back thinking look
at you you don't realize like oh he's
actually saying about yeah yeah and then
when he kills himself I haven't seen the
other stars born movies I haven't yeah
and when he kills himself I was like oh
up until I was just like no something's
gonna happen Yeah right
food apps the moment of inspiration
right he sees the pills yeah and then he
like if I get it crushes them or
something yeah or it's not gonna work
again and then he's gonna realize yeah
yeah yeah I'm gonna clarity yeah like oh
like this gonna be fun right but it's so
authentic and I think especially for the
times we live in where it seems like a
couple times a year there's some musical
artist who's committing suicide for them
to stick to that choice in this movie I
feel is so incredibly relevant that's
what it helped give it a certain yeah
Hauer fulness that I mean up and yeah at
that point the movie was is certainly
powerful but it does put a very distinct
stamp on yeah because the message of the
film is if you go to rehab you will kill
yours
[Laughter]
you're no like someone might be a dick
interpret it that way it's more than
just going to rehab that's what I'm just
going to therapy because I was thinking
that when he's like going through the
house and he's back home like there's
gotta be something laying around here
that where he might find something right
like there's gotta be he finds those
pills it's just it's like the
combination of what that dude said to
him and then the pills it makes sense
that he would kill himself and it's
heartbreaking my shot of that dog
outside the garage you know wow what a
shot the small glimpse through the
window and her having not to blame
herself as she deals with this process
of and at her Bonnie would say Oh take
it back a little bit huge to your jerk
moment Sam Elliot brings him home
oh dude and the way he tells him that
line he was the one he looks up on her
dad it was you yeah like the way he
deliver like you're like what is he
gonna say exactly ii can't express
myself right now you know that at that
concert like like you said one of the
themes of like Fame versus people don't
really know him and Sam I like say how
he's initially mad that they're playing
these songs that they really know him
and him saying this is all his fault
this is no one's fault this is his fault
of why he's dead I think it's kind of a
like beautifully tragic of how Lady Gaga
forget both she finds her voice again
she finds her musical authentic honest
side again because of the fact that he
died and by her having to complete the
song that he wrote bringing a full
circle she started a song he finished it
he started song and she finished it and
by doing that some of my argue was was
there an arc for her to find herself
again I'm like no it's it's presented at
the end of that film yeah she doesn't
have the crazy weird eye she's humbled
again you could just tell she's art to
without the film having to say it yeah
one it's the kind of movie too that has
so much my new [ __ ] in it that yeah I
mean like the arcs are gonna be a little
bit more subtle because you've been
peering in on so many already authentic
moments that don't necessarily resemble
life a bit more than your traditional
narrative lets get an easy to identify
payoff going here you know was tie these
arcs together all nicely like it's a bit
messy like life is this is
one of my favorite movies of the year
it's my favorite so far
it's definitely one of the most striking
films I've seen in a long time yeah from
the music to the performances to
direction of this movie even when you
watch a biopic an actual biopic of a
real person you're like they cover too
much they're trying to cover too much in
two hours and then here they cover like
everything it's like it's perfect do I
feel like there were some parts that
occasionally were a little
self-indulgent in terms of like the
montage of the con but it's necessary of
them performing watching them grow
together in terms of the fame and the
concert and the bit like you got to
build that partnership with them
performing together well there's so much
in the high of the of just the
performance and the creativity and it's
it's the stuff that makes these people
want to do the thing that they're doing
anyway the style does feel like a
substantial part of the movie too
because you're so often immersed in
music and immersed in emotional moments
and that all adds something to the film
there's never a time where I was like we
skip the music the point is that they're
both pursuing the music yeah and you
know it's also the music is special
because it's the one time where all
these other circumstances gets to fade
out unless you've [ __ ] up and
destroying the set or going back really
quick to the the relevance of the
suicide it like I do think that this
movie is an interesting one to comment
on that because that is sort of the
whole thesis is we think of these
performers and these celebrities being
on a different plane or being different
kinds of human but they're not like why
would they commit suicide when they have
every yeah and and this movie does a
great job of showing the the harder
little sides because it's like Bradley
Cooper struggle from that perspective is
tangible because it's like you want to
be supportive and happy for your partner
and and things like that but the little
things that affect you you can't help
the way that they affect you are true
and so yeah that moment really spoke I
thought very loud in a time of Chris
Cornell and Chester Bennington and all
these sort of shocking losses that
represent Mac Miller Mac Miller yeah
like these these shocking losses that
keep coming up life is life no matter
who you are and how you're living it it
just so happens that you get to do an
extraordinary thing a small amount of
the time this is not a movie or watching
why people problem
feels like it couldn't anybody is
because sometimes you do that later like
yeah it's not that and it's not preachy
and it's could have easily veered into
look at me try to make a melancholy
austere pitcher yeah but it's not that
either it's a movie full of so much life
in nuance yeah well the other thing too
is like as much as I cried I also spent
half the movie with a huge smile on my
face yeah that's my life movie yeah like
when he first sings that song to the to
the girl at the bar the other one of the
drag of Yammer's the bar like I I had a
grin on my face to that whole day I was
like what a beautiful moment I cried
about inspiration I cried about closure
and I cried about death yeah yeah you
know like heartbreak there's a lot I
feel like they hit all their themes
perfectly it's great movie I know
there's plenty to talk about yes Dave
Chappelle does a great job in here and
he does a great job Simon light
excellent performance is everything
about this but there's a lot of things
you could really dissect in this film
what are some of your favorite moments
in this movie or what are moments we
didn't touch on that you really that
really stood out to you in this
gentleman leave a comment below you can
subscribe to the reject nation click
that notification bell and hey check us
out on the Stardust app 30-second
reactions your film TV shows trailers a
lot of micro scratches love to have you
come up start our duster dinghy